Statistics is a discipline that makes you understand data
and make decisions based on data.
Data comes in different shapes, and sizes and colors.
If you are Google, this might be webpages.
Or in finance, these might be stocks and bonds going up and down.
I will teach you lots of basic things, like how to chart data.
We will build bar charts! We will talk about continuous data.
Such as Gaussian distributions.
You will fit curves to data, like this line over here.
We have a special track in the class, where you can program certain aspects.
But if you can't, this class can be entirely taken without any programming whatsoever.
You will be empowered to use all the basic common tools of statistics yourself.
Use them yourself, solve interesting problems
and it will forever change the way you look at data.